million pound estimate the SMP say it
will cost to build two ferries this is a
direct quote from the orchestra Journal
it would be fully to suggest that is a
reliable figure that will be spent to
deliver the vessels at this stage
so will the first Minister continue to
defend his government's estimate for
these ferries or does he agree with the
auditor general that would be folly
first Minister but what I would say and
of course I was listening to the
evidence this morning and I'll read the
rest of the evidence later on today
Douglas Ross will be aware of course the
figure that was provided to the public
audit committee on the 22nd of December
last year from the CEO of Ferguson's
Marine that has made up of a number of
different factors the Scottish
government is now reviewing these
projections based on Independent advice
that process of due diligence which is
of course important in any uh in in any
procurement of course in any uh program
of this size of this scale but
particularly given the cost overruns
even more important in the case of
Ferguson's Marine that process of due
diligence is to conclude within the next
few weeks regardless of that of course I
repeat what has been said before in this
question at rightly has been raised by
members of the opposition it is
unacceptable that we've had these cost
the overruns the fact that we have had
the delays to both 801 and 802 and again
once again
two Island communities for those cost
overruns and for those delays but we are
focused on getting these vessels
complete at solar Island communities
will see the benefit of these vessels
Douglas Ross I think even the my
cooperator had given up in that answer
and switched it off because there was
absolutely nothing there only a party
that bought a camper van for 100 grand
could think that paying hundreds or
millions of pounds for two massively
delayed ferries is a good deal and we
all know from the Scandal engulfing the
SMP that they really struggle with
finances but this is getting ridiculous
so will the first Minister stop the
secrecy and be honest for a change how
much higher is the real cost to
taxpayers going to be to deliver these
two ferries first Minister
I'm not sure I've take too many lessons
on financial literacy from the party of
Quasi karting and Liz Trust
but only
the only important issue that Douglas
Ross is absolutely right to raise in
this chamber what I have said is that
there is rightly a process of due
diligence underway that process will
conclude in the next few weeks and of
course we will make it known what the
result was what the result was of that
due diligence what I will never shy away
from seeing like rightly that of course
the cost overruns and the delays in
relation to these two vessels is
unacceptable the island communities that
are frankly frustrated and angry at
those cost delays those cost overruns
and the delays I completely accept their
frustration and their anger and
therefore we will continue to invest in
Ferguson's Marine will continue to do
what we can to get these vessels ready
in relation to the updated time scales
but that due diligence is important and
of course that will do that is due to be
complete in the next few weeks Douglas
Ross I mean the auditor general knows
the 300 million figure is fully but it
seems that the first Minister doesn't he
doesn't have a clue about the actual
cost it's going to be for taxpayers here
in Scotland the bill for these vessels
so far is already three times more than
the original contract but it gets worse
what we heard this morning and the first
Minister said he was listening to the
evidence so he will have heard the
auditor general reveal this morning that
the bonus system for highly paid
Executives at Ferguson Marine is still
in place the two ferries are not fit to
seal the cost keeps spiraling out of
control and Islanders continue to be
left without vital Lifeline Services
so first Minister who on Earth could
these bonuses possibly before first
Minister
well again again I I won't disagree with
Douglas lost or neither with the auditor
general who of course the section 22
report earlier this year made it clear
these bonuses should not have happened
they should not have been paid I I agree
if Douglas Ross will listen to the
answer I will give him genuinely an
answer members
we will hear the first Minister former
deputy first Minister made it clear his
anger we share that anger I share that
anger at the fact the bonuses have been
picked the bonuses that are being paid
of course relate to a decision made by
the remuneration Committee of Ferguson's
Marine without consultation the
government in November
2022 and those bonuses I have asked if
they can not be paid of course the
advice coming back is that they are a
contractual obligation now for future
bonuses for any future discussion or
consideration of bonuses I have made it
clear there should not be bonuses paid
in relation
801 and 802 so that has been made clear
the chair will take forward all Francis
Marines will take forward that work it
is my expectation the government's
expectation and the chair of Ferguson's
Marine knows this absolutely well that
there should not be bonuses in 23 24 The
Current financial year that we're in in
relation to this year in relation to
vessels 801 802 taco shops on every
front the SMP is engulfed in Scandal
secrecy and a shameful waste of money
they are groaning about a waste of money
when the first Minister has just
accepted how much this is going to cost
taxpayers this week the S P's
ex-treasurer Colin BT said it wasn't me
gov but he was asked about the notorious
camper van before abruptively changing
his mind and Hamza Yusuf has said he
isn't sure if Scottish government
ministers are using burner Foods that's
what the first Minister said this is all
starting to look like an episode of line
of duty but it's also a massive
distraction preventing the SNP from
getting on and delivering these vital
services to Island communities and the
problem for the first minister is he has
been personally involved in this fairy
scandal from the very beginning
he was there at the s p conference in
2015 beaming beside the disgrace Derrick
Mackay when the contract was announced
in 2016 he was behind nickel sturgeon
hoping one day he would be the first
minister to launch a ship with painted
on Windows and he was the transport
Minister inspecting the yards for years
presiding officer we found a picture of
the first Minister when he was transport
Minister visiting one of the Yards he
was there that day to Mark the halfway
point in the build of these ferries the
only problem for Hamza Yusuf is that
picture was taken at the halfway point
according to him in December
2016. more than six years ago first
Minister that wasn't the halfway point
it wasn't even the start of this sorry
Saga so how is the first Minister who
got us into this mess going to fix it
before the first Minister responds I
will just remind all members that we do
not use props in the chamber first
Minister
yeah I mean it's just a sign of Douglas
Ross's real desperation
pathetic Schoolboy tactics and ability
to raise thank you members an inability
actually to address what is a really
serious issue because I agree with the
opposition when they rightly State the
anger of Island communities that these
fairies are have not been completed so I
give an absolute commitment an absolute
guarantee to those Island communities
that we are focused and of course
Ferguson's Marines will receive the
resources that are required on the back
of that due diligence that is being done
in relation to the cost so there are
things that we should apologize for and
we will apologize for as the government
what we won't apologize for is of course
saving hundreds of jobs in Port Glasgow
at Ferguson's marine and Douglas rosters
is shaking his head I'm not surprised he
of course believes first Minister first
Minister if you will just give me a
moment
people are gathered here to hear
questions put to the first minister to
hear the first Minister respond can we
please ensure that that is possible
first Minister and the reason of course
why Douglas Ross was shaking his head
when I was mentioning the fact that we
have saved hundreds of jobs at Port
Glasgow at Ferguson's Marine is because
he belongs to our party of course that
decimated communities up and down
Scotland and left workers on the scrap
keep presiding officer
and he of course decided in his question
to take a swipe at the SNP can I remind
him of course that this week the SNP did
release its membership numbers I'm
pleased that we've seen an increase in
our membership numbers over the last few
weeks and the tour is of course demanded
that we release our membership figures
we've done that of course Douglas Ross
does not practice what he preaches he
hasn't released his membership figures
and there is award for people that don't
practice what they preach they're called
Hypocrites presiding officer
question number two anasawa
representing officer I know the first
Minister spent the past few weeks
thinking about financial mismanagement
and the criminal justice system so today
I'd like to ask him about the overspend
and the project to replace berlini
prison
because the issue of financial
mismanagement is not just about how the
SNP run their party it's about how they
govern our country
this government's failure in managing
the public finances has cost the
taxpayer more than 3.7 billion pounds
that's the result of field interventions
waste and incompetence earlier this week
it was reported that the cost of
building a new prison to replace berlini
has spiraled from 100 million pounds to
400 million pounds so can the first
Minister confirm that this project is
running over budget what he expects the
final cost to be and whether the new
president will be operational as planned
in September 2026. first Minister we are
we are this is important as we of course
raised by nasara we are looking at the
cost overruns we're seeing what can be
done to mitigate those cost overruns I
think we all agree in relation to the
fact that berlini is not in the
condition that any of us would like it
to be in so we are exploring uh what can
be done can I just say to honest that
way I think he does the debate a
disservice when he talks about the
figure that he used over three billion
pounds of wastages describes it in
reference to that I've seen the labor
press release it talks about decisions
that are for the crown for example the
Rangers prosecution that is not a that
is not a decision for the SNP government
that is an independent uh decision of
course for the crown and procreator
fiscal service so does nobody else it
does affect a disservice to the debate
uh to include uh figures like that it's
what we are interrogating the figures in
relation uh to berlini of course
construction costs have increased for a
whole number of reasons for of course
partly to do with the UK government's
complete mismanagement of the economy
but also to do with some Global factors
as well we know the the war against
Ukraine the illegal Invasion by Russia
of course has also affected uh
construction costs as well but to give
him a direct answer to his question
those cost overruns are being
interrogated and we'll do everything we
can to bring them down and a Star Wars
Jason the first Minister wants to
dispute 60 million pounds out of 3.7
billion tons of waste under this SMP
government and I'm sorry believing
Ukraine or The Wider economic crisis or
inflation on this crisis is not going to
work the this is a three this is a 300
increase in costs
inflation is running at 10 even in SMP
Treasurer can tell you those figures
don't add up because Scotland's prison
estate is in a dire condition at
Greenwich prison the Chief Inspector of
Prisons is threatening to bring in the
health and safety executive because of
the state of the building and Inverness
the prisons inspector has said the
prison is not fit for purpose that
prison was due to be replaced at an
original cost of 52 million pounds that
cost has now risen to almost 140 million
pounds in fact in all five major Capital
programs in the criminal justice system
all are running over budget so if the
first man Minister truly believes in
transparency will he commit to opening
up the books and where do you welcome an
audit Scotland review into these
projects so we can understand why costs
are running out of control first
minister
again I mean any accessible suggestions
around the course of overruns I'm happy
to take away and to explore but it is
astonishing that Alice Howard seems to
suggest that these Global factors as
well as of course domestic factors are
in relation to inflation don't have any
bearing on construction costs I think
that is not the reality of course what
has not helped our economy what hasn't
helped the economy at all is of course a
hard brexit which is Now supported by
the Scottish labor party quite
unbelievably too so honest hour is of
course right to stand up here and to
question the course be of hmp berliniana
did the other presidents and indeed a
lot of infrastructure projects
absolutely correct uh to do so and they
will be interrogated you can vet your
bottom dollar that they will be
interrogated because of course we are we
are absolutely in really challenging
Financial circumstances again no thanks
to the UK government but what I would
say to anastas and his party was in
charge of course their PFI Pro we are
still having to pay we are still having
to pay a quarter of a billion in PFI
payments because of the Scottish labor
party that certainly doesn't help our
budget in any way shape or form and a
Star Wars
the uh the first Minister talked about
desperation earlier on it is really
really desperate to see that a 300
increase in the cost of Berlin prison is
due to some Global factors around
Ukraine and perhaps even Vladimir Putin
and it's also desperate 16 years into an
SMP government to talk about decisions
made by a government when the first
Minister was 12 years old
and take responsibility for a change I
would be grateful when Mr sarwar is
putting his question if we could hear it
and if members could resist the
temptation to make comment at that point
Mr Sharon I can understand why they're
frustrating officers so maybe get them a
bit of slack this week and maybe in
future weeks as well because right
across the public sector project after
project is running out of control in
health the new beard Family Hospital in
Aberdeen initial budget 163 million now
244 million in education a new college
campus and in firmland initial budget 86
million new budget 119 million and of
course in transport replacement ferries
for Lifeline routes initial budget 97
million now running close to 300 million
while families across Scotland are
working out how to make ends meet this
SMP government and this first ministers
incompetence is allowing millions of
pounds to disappear this is a government
that's been in power for 16 years and
has lost grip on taxpayers money and
weakened every institution in our
country Scotland can no longer afford
this chaotic dysfunctional SMP
government arrogant and competency so is
there any wonder that people are
concluding that it's time for change
first Minister
when it comes to the important issues of
inequality and Poverty of course that
will be and continues to be a defining
mission for this government that's why
of course we've invest in that
game-changing Scottish child payment
which we know Has Lifted at many
hundreds of thousands uh out of of
poverty when it comes to the fuel and
Security fund that was one of the first
announcements right the first
announcement I made as first Minister
not just to double it but of course uh
to Triplet our social security uh
Scotland we have a number of benefits
there's seven benefits that are
available only in Scotland are social
security system that is based on
fairness dignity and compassion so that
is of course our focus when it comes to
tackling uh inequality Anna Star Wars
says we are desperate talking about
decisions made uh by the last Labor
government I agree with them there's
many many many moons ago and for good uh
reason and of course Jackie Bailey was
in government very briefly uh in
government at that point but it is
important to say the reason why we're
still talking about it the reason why we
still talking about it is because we are
still paying for it and deliver mortgage
our future
the labor party the Scottish labor party
didn't just mortgage our future their
mortgage and our children's future as
well so the fact that we are having to
pay hundreds of millions in PFI payments
uh 16 years on uh is in fact is is
undoubtedly uh the reason why Anna Sawa
doesn't want us talking about it but
presiding officer the proportion issues
around construction of our prisons of
our infrastructure projects I take
seriously this government seriously and
I can give them an absolute promise that
we are doing everything we can to bring
those costs down
[Applause]
thank you very much uh presiding officer
to ask the first Minister when the
cabinet will next meet first Minister
Tuesday
oh it's called Hamilton
I'm very grateful for that reply uh
presiding officer it's enough to fill 19
000 Olympic-sized swimming pools that's
how much sewage we know was dumped into
our Rivers last year by Scotland's
government-owned water company I say no
because only one in 20 discharge pipes
are actually monitored but in addition
to this new liberal Democrat research
that we are publishing today reveals
over 400 sewage dumps in the vicinity of
some of Scotland's best beaches last
year from peterhead to Saint Andrews
these award-winning beaches should be
protected and pristine they draw
tourists families and wild swimmers but
like so many other things on the first
Minister's desk right now this
absolutely stinks so could I ask the
first Minister will he now instruct the
monitoring of all sewage discharges in
Scotland and what will he do to help
Scottish water get a handle on this
otherwise
how many swimming pools of Pooh is he
content to see put on our best loved
beaches Minister well this is
the CSU and article happens of course is
right to to to raise it what I would say
of course that our beaches and he
mentions a number of them uh in his
question uh to me uh our world-class
tourist destination so I don't want to
see a single sewage dump where it is
absolutely unnecessary so I will take up
the issue personally with Scottish
Waters I know my cabinet uh secretary is
doing that directly with Scottish water
so he has right to absolutely raise the
issue I will look at it personally
myself I will raise it personally myself
with Scottish water and come back to the
member course
question number four Stephanie Callahan
to ask the first Minister what the
Scottish government's responses to
alcohol-focused Scotland's emergency
call to urgently take action to prevent
further deaths and reduce harm from
alcohol first Minister well first and
foremost my deepest sympathy and I
suspect or the deepest sympathy of all
of the chamber goes to those that have
been affected by the Lost Love a loved
one through alcohol we remained
absolutely determined to reduce
alcohol-related harm that's why we've
introduced initiatives such as our world
leading minimum minimum unit pricing
Recent research of course estimates has
saved hundreds of lives as outlined last
week I'm absolutely committed to
reviewing the current level of minimum
unit pricing alongside other ongoing
works such as the upcoming UK alcohol
treatment guidelines development of
alcohol treatment targets for April 2024
and the expansion of our residential
rehab capacity by 50 by the end of this
Parliament at last year 106.8 million
was made available to alcohol and drugs
Partnerships support local and National
initiatives we'll carefully consider the
points that have been raised by
alcohol-focused Scotland and the
minister for drugs and alcohols due to
meet with them and other stakeholders in
the coming weeks to discuss our approach
to tackling alcohol harm so Stephanie
Callahan I thank the first Minister for
his answer and I know you'll agree that
the ongoing alcohol emergency requires a
public health-wide policy response to
save even more lives in religious Health
inequalities
so with this in mind I really appreciate
the update there on the developing
alcohol treatment targets and are you
able to say anything about the alcohol
deep interventions thank you first
Minister that's a really important Point
raised by Stephanie Callahan in relation
to alcohol brief interventions we've
been absolutely committed to our ABI
delivery program it's been in place for
10 years we've seen excellent progress
and sustained delivery of the national
ABI program across Scotland today and
can I congratulate local Partners on the
Fantastic achievement of that the
alcohol framework it does make a
commitment to reviewing the evidence on
current delivery of abis to ensure
they've been carried out in the most
effective manner so we're working with
public health Scotland to review the
evidence and the current delivery of
alcohol brief interventions to determine
how the system could be better could
better meet the needs of individuals and
I will update the member in due course
once that review has been complete Carol
Morgan
thank you proceeding officer we know
from National records of Scotland and
alcohol-focused Scotland the
alcohol-specific death rates in
Scotland's most deprived areas are over
five times higher than in the least
deprived areas similarly with hospital
stays linked to alcohol we see these six
times as high in our most deprived
deprived communities compared to our
most affluent this is a there is a clear
need for improved access to
alcohol-related support services and our
most deprived areas who are being badly
let down by this government the alcohol
related and wider Health inequalities
that exist in our country are both deep
and divisive his predecessor did little
to address them how can the country have
any confidence that he will do any
better first Minister
I don't agree with that final point of
course that was my predecessor when she
was Health secretary that introduced
minimum unit pricing for alcohol and of
course it was successive Health
secretaries at the time of course that
made sure we push the head in the face
of considerable opposition our minimum
unit for placing for alcohol and my
understanding of course there was a
considerable opposition from Scottish
Labor uh two minimum unit pricing of
alcohol and when she talks about saving
at like sorry when Carol Morgan talks
about saving lives it's worth saying
that research about minimum unit pricing
alcohol has shown us that more than 150
lives a year have been saved and have
resulted the mup has also resulted in
411 fewer Hospital admissions we're also
encouraging to see that that research
and I'm happy to share a copy with Carol
Morgan because it's directly related to
her question that the policy is having
an effect in Scotland's most deprived
areas which experience higher death
rates and levels of alcohol of harm from
problem alcohol usage so I'm happy to
give Carol Morgan further detail of what
more can be done but I'm I'm confident
in seeing that this government is taking
action and alcohol time particularly in
areas of highest deprivation really
rainy
and you study from the University of
Glasgow found a correlation between the
minimum unit pricing and the 13.4
reduction in deaths but the 50 pence
rate was set over a decade ago and
inflation has been raging since so we do
need a change to catch up so will the
first Minister bring forward that review
of minimum unit pricing operate it from
50 pence and bring forward legislation
to tie it to inflation to save lives in
the future
first Minister can I could I uh be
credit to other lady I know he has
raised this issue many many times when I
was Health secretary you raise the issue
with me uh a few times as well and he
makes a really important point about the
research really really well of course
know because he was in Parliament at the
time that there was robust legal
challenge in relation to minimum unit uh
pricing so we are ensuring of course
that when it comes to review of minimum
unit pricing that we have as robust
evidence in place if there ever was to
be another legal challenge to a
potential increase in the minimum unit
uh pricings was so important that that
we do have that robust evidence base to
just to determine and support any
decision on a change in level of mup the
conclusion of the review of the level of
mup will be concluded in late 2023 it
really really has asked me to look to
see if that can be brought forward I of
course will do that I'll have that
discussion but I just go back to my
first point of course it's so important
that we have robust evidence in place
for any decision that is made in
relation to minimum unit pricing
question number five Jamie green
thank you to ask the first Minister what
the Scottish government's responses to
new police Scotland statistics showing
that the number of recorded rapes has
increased to its highest level in six
years first Minister let me see first
and foremost that it is abhorrent that
women continue to face violence and and
rape and we will continue to take robust
action to tackle sexual offending
through Scotland's equally safe strategy
focused on prevention on improving
support and modernizing the law it's
vitally important that anyone who faces
violence sexual violence rape in
particular has a confidence and support
to report these crimes and that the
justice system does respond that Jimmy
Green will be well aware in fact I think
I heard them on the radio this morning
speaking about the victims Witnesses and
Justice Reform Scotland Bill introduced
to Parliament this week that will
further strengthen the response of the
justice system putting victims and
Witnesses crucially at the very heart of
the justice system it also proposes to
implement the significant reforms that
were recommended by Lady Dorian in her
report to improve the management of
sexual offenses including a specialist
court for sexual offending Jamie Greene
can I thank the first Minister and Echo
many of the comments he's made and we
should also as Parliament commend The
Bravery of those who do come forward to
report this horrific crime but I think
it's a dangerous assumption to make that
a rise in recorded cases is simply a
byproduct of more people coming forward
and not an underlying rise in the levels
of crime of this nature itself and
that's sort of qualitative work I would
expect the government to already be
doing in this regard the real problem
providing officers that the entire
system from end to end is letting
victims of crime down from the initial
reporting experience to the lengthy
delays in getting trials to come to pass
up to four years in some cases it's
horrendous the court experience itself
is re-traumatizing and even if and isn't
if a conviction is secured and we all
know that conversion rates are seriously
law in Scotland the victim of that crime
faces the Injustice of watching the
perpetrator dished out a lenient
sentence relative to the gravity of the
crime that was committed against that
victim so what I would say to the first
Minister as a former Justice secretary
himself as if he will make a personal
commitment today to those victims of
this horrific crime though he will
undertake a root and branched review of
how this country handles and processes
cases of rape will The Undertaker review
into why these figures are at such high
levels in Scotland and we will he commit
to work working with victims
organizations and victims themselves to
finally put them at the heart of this
justice system far too many women have
been let down by the system and that's
got to change presiding officer first
Minister
can I thank Jimmy Green for what was a
really important question and some many
of the points I agree with some uh
perhaps I will I will I will try to
address and come back to him in writing
further detail what I would say is he's
right we don't make an assumption that
the The Rising case is simply down to
Greater reporting and greater awareness
so it's fair to say uh in terms of
non-recent cases historical cases we
have seen a rise uh in in the reporting
and that's not just the case in Scotland
we know that's the case right across the
UK and I suspect to many jurisdictions
uh right across the world and there has
been a focus on trying to raise
awareness of reporting cases of rape and
sexual offenses in particular there's
also been a greater consistency and
approach in the use of Specialists
police officers in this regard as well
in terms of a few of the points that
Jimmy Green raises and I think he is
absolutely right to raise them that is
the entire purpose of course of the
victim's Witnesses and and Justice
Reform Bill that has been introduced it
is putting victims and Witnesses at the
heart of our justice system I uh um as
we have the great pleasure of meeting a
number of family is an activist
campaigners victims Witnesses survivors
yesterday at a meeting to discuss the
bell I say great pleasure because of the
most horrific circumstances and enormous
tragedy they have been at the heart of
campaigning through their bravery
through their courage for better reform
to the justice system and the bill that
we have introduced I think it's fair to
say by any objective measure is bold
it's ambitious probably the biggest
change that we will see in our justice
system if the bill has passed in decades
some might even say longer than that and
what I would say to to Jamie green is
he's asked for a root and Branch review
I think of sexual offenses and and rape
cases of course that review was done by
Lady Dorian and of course many of the
recommendations or many of the uh
Clauses within the bill are a direct
result of that work done by Lady Dorian
so we'll continue to invest in the
justice system to continue to bring
those court-back logs down in their are
of course falling that what I would say
to Jamie green is that Angela Constance
cabinet secretary for justice and home
Affairs who's leading uh this bill she
will be engaging with every single
opposition member as you'd expect her to
and of course we will take this bill
forward in this open-minded in a
constructive way so we can take
hopefully all of this Parliament uh
through these Justice reforms together
Colleen McNeil
these alarming statistics and rate but a
further indication of ingrained levels
of violence against women and misogyny
across our society Scottish labor has
been running a consultation with the
full involvement of government officials
to tackle violence against women but
sadly it has confirmed existing research
that young girls have been subjected to
a rape culture and skills in the cross
University campuses and many receiving
unwanted sexual images of becoming too
normalized Behavior I hope the first
Minister will agree with me though we
need to tackle the root cause of the
problem in our society by talking
directly to boys and young men in all of
our schools and our campuses to talk
about their attitude to women and girls
first Minister I mean I I couldn't agree
more with Pauline McNeil's question and
the statements that she makes when I was
just a secretary again obviously I had
the pleasure of seeing a program being
delivered in the school not too far away
from this Parliament which was directly
talking to young boys particularly
around the issue of consent and it was a
really engaging uh session that was had
there and probably was absolutely right
we have to tackle the root cause the
root cause unfortunately as predatory
men and we have to intervene as early as
we possibly can and I support everything
that Pauline McNeil said in her question
we have as a government supported and
will continue to support Emily's test I
know Plumbing he was very aware of the
Fantastic work that is done by Fiona Dre
and of course by Emily's Family are
again of terrible a horrific tragedy
using that tragedy to make sure that
nobody else hopefully has to suffer what
Emily had to suffer so we've supported
the Emily's test to create his
groundbreaking gender-based violence
chart I think it's really initiative of
its kind in the UK what I finally say
deployment Neil if I heard her correctly
I believe she said that the Scottish
labor party were undertaking their own
consultation when that is ready to be
published if you've been mentioning that
with me personally but of course with
the cabinet secretary for justice and
home Affairs I'd be very very interested
in the results of that Constitution
number six Jackie Bailey to ask this
first Minister what the Scottish
government is doing to ensure that
publish NHS waiting times for treatment
are accurate first Minister public
statistics are collated and quality
assured by public health Scotland
they're published as part of the full
release of national statistics each
quarter National statistics status means
that the official statistics meet the
highest standards the higher standards
of trustworthiness of quality of public
value the UK statistics Authority has
designated PHS starts as National
statistics therefore therefore
signifying their compliance with the
code of practice for statistics Jackie
Bailey there there are of course one in
seven Scots on waiting lists currently
and Senior clinicians have warned that
the waiting time statistics published on
NHS in form are both inaccurate and
misleading I wrote to the UK statistics
Authority in October last year they
agreed and asked the Scottish government
to make changes six months later and
very little has changed clinicians are
still up in arms about the stats being
skewed the Scottish government continues
to use median waiting times and mixes
emergency and elective care so can I ask
the first Minister will he now stop
pulling the ball over people's eyes
Rectify this misleading data and can he
tell us did he publish the stats whilst
knowing about the criticism of their
flaws fish minister no we did not and of
course we read the letter receiver
letter from the status Authority and of
course I engaged with Scots that's got
Society of Orthopedic
Consultants and I and and of course I'm
I'm sure the cabin secretary for health
will continue to meet uh with the same
organization is incorrect for Jackie
Bailey to suggest that changes weren't
made so she's right of course we'll just
leave that letter uh in October
2022 we then worked with public health
Scotland and NHS 24 to review and
address those key points that were made
of following the recommendations from
the office of statistic regulations we
made a number of changes that included
for example highlighting both the
strength and indeed the limitations that
the data shown showed on the website
there is also now additional links for
the full release of national statistics
on the PHS website that provides further
information uh just further information
relation to the distribution of waiting
times for patients who have completed
their weights but also those who are
still waiting and in terms of
um the criticism from the Scottish
committee for Orthopedics and Trauma
Scott the cabinet secretary for Health
and Social care well of course continue
to meet with them but can I commend them
and their members and all of those
working in NHS Scotland for the fact
that despite significant ongoing
pressure of course we have seen that the
number of outpatients waiting longer
than two years for a new outpatient
appointment has reduced by 50 since
September 2022 and by over 60 since June
2022.
thank you we moved to General and
constituency supplementaries and I call
clear Hobby
thank you presiding officer the first
Minister may be aware that South
lanarkshire Council has recently
increased the cost to local youth teams
and clubs who hire football pitches
swimming pools and Halls by up to 114
percent
I've spoken with many from across
radical and constituency who fear they
cannot afford this and are worried that
the clubs may have to fold
does the first Minister agree with me
that the labor administration at South
lanarkshire Council should be focusing
on increasing uptake of sports and
physical activity that temporarily
suspending the increase isn't good
enough and that instead they should be
scrapping these damaging Place increases
without further delay
can I um before the first Minister
responds can I just remind members of
the requirement to that questions should
relate to matters for which the Scottish
government has General responsibility
and if you can answer in that light
first Minister mobile is clearly for
local administrations to determine their
own priorities but like clear hockey
frankly I'm appalled at the actions of
Labor leads Authority in South
lanarkshire I saw a protest taking place
by young people suggesting that it was
time for Joe Joe Fagan the leader of
South Lancaster Council to go I have to
say I think those young people have
frankly a very good judgment indeed so
while families are facing ongoing
eye-watering hikes and food and energy
bills having to cut back another
expenditure this is not the right time
to ramp up these charges and potentially
deny children and young people in
constituencies like Ruther Glen the
chance to take part in sports so I can
only hope that the council sense and
turn this temporary reprieve into a
permanent one murder freezer
thank you presiding officer on Friday
last week tayside Aviation based in
Dundee went into Administration with the
immediate loss of 22 jobs
tastes like the aviation partnered with
a number of universities providing
degree courses in Pilot training
students on these courses some of them
my constituents now face an uncertain
future not able to complete their
degrees and having lost thousands of
pounds in fees paid upfront to taste
like Aviation which may not be
recoverable some students have student
loans now to repay but nothing to show
for the money so how can the Scottish
government help my constituents caught
in this desperate situation
Easter
important issue another phase of motor
phase of course is right to raise it
here I'm very saddened to hear of the
job losses at tastes Aviation my
thoughts of course are with the workers
that have been affected their families
and rightly so with the students as well
and I appreciate this position has has
put students in great difficulty
understand their concerns about money
that they've paid for lessons and
anybody impacted it should of course
contact The Joint administrators further
information including links to the Joint
administrators insolvency portal are on
the Tay side Aviation website we're
actively taking steps to understand how
this will impact students funded by the
Scottish government Universe students
should have been contacted directly by
their University and we're also engaging
with Middlesex University who are
delivery partners for that course I
should have said in terms of the workers
as well our Pace team uh stand ready to
be able to offer any assistance they can
it will continue due to examine explore
this issue to see what we can do to
minimize the impact in the students in
particular and I'll report back to
murder Fraser in due course clear Baker
and thank you exciting officer so last
week yes recycling five entered
Administration as a result of cash flow
difficulties stemming from its inability
to operate at fuel capacity only opened
in September last year as a
state-of-the-art recycling center and
now 60 jobs are on the brink it received
520 000 pounds from the circular economy
investment fund administered by zero way
Scotland with funding from the European
Regional Development Fund and the
Scottish Scottish government can I ask
what discussions the Scottish government
have had to determine why after less
than a year this important facility has
collapsed and has been unable to operate
at fuel capacity and what support the
Scottish government are offering to the
employees first Minister I am concerned
about the difficulty at yes recycling
finds itself in and of course my
thoughts with those 60 staff members
that are working at the company and the
facility at England Glen rothas this
will be a very very difficult time for
the staff and indeed for their families
to give her some reassured in Scottish
Enterprise as engaging with the
administrator I will provide all
possible assistance to help to maintain
jobs at the site in the unfortunate
event any individual should be facing
redundancy the Scottish government will
provide support through Pace the
partnership action for continuing
employment peace have I understand
reached out to the administrator to
offer support to the affected staff and
I can confirm that a local Pace team has
provided information on the support
available for employees and has
requested to meet with the administrator
so hopefully through providing skills
development and employment support that
pays William to minimize the time
individuals affected by redundancy are
out of work but I will take everything
that clear baker has said away and see
if there's anything further we can do in
relation to a very very difficult
situation at rest recycling in
Glenrothes Frank issuing
thank you thank you presiding officer
will the first Minister welcome the
announcement this week of a planned
investment by Quantum Energy Partners to
a value of 300 million pounds in my
constituency an investment which will
focus on a Titan artists here that will
develop a work in offshore wind and also
oil decommissioning and which will bring
massive benefits possibly for the
remainder of the century in terms of
employment in the renewable energy field
does he agree that this development
strengthens yet further the case for the
dueling of the a96
a case which is supported uh presiding
officer by over 90 percent 90 percent of
the readers of the excellent press and
journal the authentic voice of the North
and will he
and will he expedite at long last the
delivery of the dueling of the section
from Inverness to aldern including the
nirna bypass first Minister yes I do
welcome that news of course of that a
very important investment indeed
decommissioning is integral to the
pursuit of an orderly managed transition
to Net Zero and has the potential to
create significant benefits and
opportunities for people right across
Scotland since 2017 for our own
decommissioned decommissioning challenge
fund the Scottish government has
invested 12 million pounds to support
Innovation and build capacity in the
decommissioning sector turning to roads
we remain absolutely committed to
improving the a96 and the current plan
is of course to fully do the routes but
we are currently undertaking a review as
the member knows of this Corridor with
the outcomes expected this summer for
consultation in addition we remain
absolutely committed to during the
Inverness to near section including the
near bypass and we'll complete the
strategy process for that as soon as
possible and taste White
thank you presiding officer first
Minister last night for the second time
the screening of the documentary adult
human female at Edinburgh University had
to be canceled as protesters blockaded
entrances to The Venue women were shut
out and discussion about women's rights
was shut down
do you agree that freedom of speech
should be defended in our academic
institutions and will you join me in
urging Edinburgh University to ensure
the event can take place
first Minister I do agree with uh Tess
white about the importance of freedom of
speech and more so in our educational
institutions like our universities that
there should be a space that a safe
space for debate discussion robust is
that may well be be of course I haven't
seen the film in question the adult
human female film I don't know the
contents of it my understanding is that
there was a protest against the film
taking place and then there was a
separate protest which ended up denying
those who wanted to see the film access
to the screening now it is of course a
matter for Edinburgh University I won't
look to intervene in that sense but I
think I've made it perfectly clear in
relation to my stance on freedom of
speech particularly within universities
now I see that there's no conflict with
the other stance that I'm very proud of
which is supporting trans rights that is
something I am unequivocal about but we
should ensure that our universities uh
out of place or universities and Society
more generally at a place where we can
have that even robust exchange of ideas
so I do I'm sure Edinburgh University
have heard what I've had to say and what
Tess white has had to say but it is
really important that this is ultimately
a decision uh for uh Edinburgh
University to take
item of business is a member's business
debate in the name of Marianne Burgess
and there'll be a short suspension now
to allow those leaving the chamber and
public gallery to do so before the
debate begins